die spuren des libanesischen
bürgerkriegs sind gerade erst geteilt
und nun kehren sie den schritt von dem
beirut bei seite der stadt die sie in
den letzten jahren erst wieder aufgebaut
haben alles freiwillige hier sie sind
aus dem ganzen land gekommen um zu
helfen um zusammenzustehen solidarität
zeigen in dieser schweren zeit
was soll ich sagen das einzige was wir
versuchen können ist zu helfen wo auch
immer vielleicht es ist nur ein kleiner
beitrag die straße aufräumen das
zerbrochene glas den schutt was auch
immer hauptsache wir helfen uns
gegenseitig und stillen zusammen hand
anlegen improvisieren reparieren
dort wo es noch etwas zu flicken gibt
niemand hier wartet auf hilfe vom staat
zu oft schon wurden sie enttäuscht wir
haben keine regierung die handelt
manchmal musst du maßnahmen ergreifen
und die dinge in die eigene hand nehmen
es ist der zweite tag nach der explosion
die solidarität der libanesen scheint
ebenso grenzenlos wie ihr frust über die
eigene regierung schalten wir zu unserem
nahost korrespondenten oligarch uli ist
man weiter bei der frage wer für diese
katastrophe verantwortlich ist nein es
ist alles noch ziemlich nebulös aber
immerhin macht man sich auf die suche
nach schuldigen einige mitarbeiter der
hafenverwaltung wurden unter hausarrest
gestellt mittlerweile gibt es aber auch
hinweise dass genau aus dieser
hafenverwaltung seit jahren schon
anträge an die regierung gestellt wurden
fragen was man mit diesem material mit
ammonium nicht mitmachen soll es sei
hochexplosiv das war bekannt und
jahrelang wurde seitens der regierung
seien zur institution die sich auf die
verwaltung eben allein gelassen es ist
nichts passiert es ist eine sache die
ins bild mit der libanesischen regierung
passt die sich vor allem um sich selbst
kümmern und ihre eigene taschen zu
füllen
das land letztendlich allein lässt wie
die sache weitergeht welche schuldigen
endlich wie vorgeführt werden und für
diese sache verantwortlich gemacht
werden das wird man sehen
die untersuchungen laufen sie sollen
unabhängig sein mit einer
internationalen expertenkommission
man wird sehen was dabei rauskommt